how you doing
steve how you doing i'm doing excellent
i can't see you
oh i was gonna say i can't wait for the
kids that are gonna watch this movie
uh to watch you in narcos yeah that's
what i'm talking about
you know like you know
dismantle those child restrictions on
the netflix you know
uh go straight to numbers so
i have to ask um a number of years ago
you worked with david
e kelly on the wonder woman tv pilot
yeah
yeah did you did you think okay there's
no way i'm getting this role
because i've already done the wonder
woman thing and it didn't work out
you know i think that somehow
i hadn't thought of it until until after
i really loved that david e kelly uh
wonder woman project
i was devastated when it didn't get
picked up to series um
but this is such a such a different in
car
this is such a different invention you
know that um
that that having seen the first wonder
woman and then talking to patty about
this one
i think that it it it it's just so
it's so bold it's so complete and it's
so rich that
i had forgotten about everything i'd
ever done in my life
much less that pilot got it uh
i know that there's always deleted
scenes in every movie uh did your
character
have any deleted scenes that you wish
were in the movie
in um in wonder woman 1984 underwood in
1984
i don't know how patty did it but they
created with this movie something that
almost functions as a four-hander
and for that to exist with such a great
balance
for the experience of the movie i am not
i don't even want to know how hard she
fought for the edit because
there isn't a lot in there that that
that didn't that didn't stay
um that that got cut you know it's the
first for me
gotta get cut out a lot no comment on
that
uh listen before i run out of time with
you i'm obviously like everybody else a
massive mandalorian fan
um obviously you're not on set all the
time
i am curious though is there a day or a
scene
that you wish you were the one in the
suit that day there's a
a lot of experiences of being on that
set that that there isn't really a set
that i haven't seen
and um and and i all i can tell you is
that
there are instances where um
being there and and for example getting
to do a scene with this large
ant creature playing cards with amy
sedaris
and her riffing uh with john favreau
just off camera
while my face gets to do whatever it
wants under the mask
is uh is something that i'll definitely
never forget
on that note i need to go i just want to
say congrats on everything you've been
doing
thank you so much for your time thanks
steve be good